hey what's going on guys it's been about
a week since I've uploaded a video so I
just want to remind everybody that you'd
still have a chance to win the complete
Game of Thrones series on blu-ray for
those of you that are new here this
might be the first time that you're ever
listening to one of my videos I'm doing
a brand new giveaway and I'm going to be
given away the entire Game of Thrones
series on blu-ray seasons 1 through 6 on
blu-ray one of you guys can one net just
like this video subscribe to this
channel and after you're finished
watching this go down to the description
and I will provide a link down there
and just follow those directions in that
way you can have multiple ways to try to
win this game of Thrones collection on
blu-ray so I want to thank everybody who
has participated in that but let's get
the video started and today I want to
share something with you that I just
came across the other day and personally
I think this is pretty significant but I
want you guys to be the judge I'm going
to show you a short video clip and you
guys tell me what you think it means but
personally I think it damn near confirms
that season 7 plot leaked the other day
I got on YouTube and I noticed this
video was being recommended to me and I
wasn't even going to click on it to be
honest with you because I wasn't really
sure what it was but when I read the
description it said that Daniel Portman
was on there and he was being
interviewed so I figured I would listen
to a few minutes of it just to at least
check it out and this podcast was just
uploaded to YouTube on January 29 2017
so it's only a few days old in Daniel
portman who's the man that's being
interviewed he portrays Podrick in the
game of Thrones television series and
during his interview he is asked about
the script that he receives for the
upcoming seasons and that's when he
drops a bombshell about all the leaks
that have came out and I'm going to add
the link to this podcast down in the
description just in case you guys want
to watch the whole interview for
yourself but in the clip I'm about to
show you Daniel aka Podrick talks about
how the entire episodes were leaked
before which I am assuming he meant
during season 5 when the first four
episodes were leaked online which I'm
sure some of you probably remember that
but then he talks about this season
season 7 and well you guys just have a
listen for yourself it's pretty damn
interesting
so I feel like and again I think you for
you've been yeah when you when'd you get
the script and how long ahead you get
the script now it's not it's not very
far ahead of time left so there's been
so many leaks over the years now in
terms of episode school and I think that
season we had a whole table full of
synopsis for the next II don't know if
you guys have seen that the leak did you
guys hear what he said he said this year
we had a whole table full of synopsis
leaked for the next season meaning
season seven the fact that he even
mentions it makes me think that it's
real and he is definitely aware of it I
think if the leak was fake then he
wouldn't have said anything about it at
all but I think this definitely adds
some weight to all the speculation
that's been going around about whether
or not the leaks are real but since he
only briefly mentioned it I'm going to
let you guys be the judge I don't want
to say this is definitely what he's
talking about but to me it appears that
he's talking about the season seven plot
leaked and after reading the plot leaked
I wasn't sure if it was going to be real
or not but after hundreds of photos and
dozens of reports came out that backed
up the leak it kind of became harder and
harder to ignore the fact that the leak
may be true and after hearing this
interview with Podrick and him saying
that an entire table full of synopsis
were leaked for season seven I think
it's obvious now that the majority of
that original season seven plot leaked
is going to be true let's listen to that
video clip one more time just to clarify
what he actually said it was almost it
like meeting came in front
why didn't you be used when when you get
the script and how long ahead you get
the script now it's not it's not very
far ahead of time left so there's been
so many leaks over the years now in
terms of episodes going I think that
season we had a whole table full of
synopsis for the next see I don't know
if you guys have seen that the week I
don't know guys it seems pretty obvious
to me but comment below and tell me what
you guys think about this it could mean
nothing or it could be exactly what I
think it is I want you guys to be the
judge
but anyways when I get off work tonight
I'm going to be doing my first collab
video with another game of Thrones
youtuber his channel is called sir hunts
were
views which I will add has link down in
the description so you can go check out
his channel we have gone back and forth
trying to decide what type of collab
videos we wanted to give you guys so
tonight I think we're going to do a full
season 7 breakdown on the character
Brand Stark we're going to give our
predictions about this character when I
was just going to use the photos in a
plot league but we're going to give our
own predictions and we're going to dig
deep into this character and what we
think his purpose is going to be during
season 7 and I'm going to upload this
video to my channel then the next
character breakdown we do we are going
to upload it to his channel so make sure
you subscribe to his channel so you can
see all of our collabs that we're going
to do together and if you guys enjoy
these collabs then we're going to give
our predictions and breakdowns for every
single character so I hope you guys
enjoy these type of videos we're going
to do together we're going to do a bunch
of recording tonight after I get off
work so the brand start video should be
uploaded by tomorrow on Saturday I
appreciate you guys for taking the time
to watch this and keeping an eye out for
the future videos thank you and thank
you for all your support and kind words
I will see you guys in the comments
section let's talk about what Podrick
just said in that interview